So web.xml defines configurations for web apps.
Lots of web apps use web.xml, not just
App eEngine apps and not just Maven
projects. So pom.xml is for your Maven dependencies
in your Maven project. In pom.xml you
can list all the dependencies for your project,
like which version of JUnit, which version of App Engine SDK you want. And when
you compile your project, Maven will automatically
get all the dependencies for it. And
appengine-web.xml is where you configure things specific
to App Engine. So App Engine configs
here. And there are more XML files specific to App Engine such as q.xml,
cron.xml and you're going to be learning about
those as you work through the course.